Arizona Senator Jeff Flake also wants
Congress to take action the Republican
is proposing laws to ban bump stocks and
prevent individuals who are on the
no-fly list from buying guns Blake also
introduced a bill to raise the minimum
age to buy assault weapons from 18 to 21
senator flake is with us here for an
interview you'll only see on CBS this
morning good morning senator thanks
Rodney all of you here before we get
into the specifics I want to speak more
generally about the president he said in
that meeting I think it's time that a
president stepped up is he now on your
side is he gonna step up and what would
that need to look like I hope he does
his leadership here is really critical
it's going to get through the house in
the Senate we had a similar meeting on
immigration that I was at and we heard a
lot of good things that Tuesday and by
Thursday a lot of it had been walked
back I hope this time and I do think
there's a better chance this time that
the president will lead and and really
get out front on this and there are a
couple of items that we can make
progress on and what his leadership look
like does it mean he has to say I want
ABC indeed to pass does it mean getting
on the phone and calling Republicans
what is it exactly look certainly the
latter to get on the phone and and say
hey I'm going to sign this if it comes
to my desk that gives Republicans in
Congress cover if the president is on
their side they don't have to worry so
much about activist groups or the NRA or
grassroots organizations that that may
think differently so it's extremely
important for the president to lead here
what did you make of that meeting though
yesterday senator eyes I saw a lot of
people use the word that they were
astonished I saw an interview with you
where you said I don't know if we got a
Tuesday Trump or a Wednesday what did
you make of what you were hearing and
seeing well it was remarkable for him to
say hey you know but this is part of the
bill why don't you have this as part of
the bill most remarkable was his
statement on due process anything that
we have introduced in the Congress
respects due process you've got to do
that so it was a bit astonishing to hear
his language there and people around
there we're shaking the table were kind
of shaking their heads but you can you
can chalk that up to just he misspoke
let's move ahead so I think there was a
lot of excitement afterwards that he
might actually lead on this and we need
that
senator the the president also said the
NRA has great power over new people you
are endorsed by the NRA in 2012 you
accepted campaign donations from them
what is it going to take to break the
spell between certain members of
Congress and the National Rifle
Association like most of my colleagues
sometimes I agree with the NRA sometimes
I don't I've always supported and in the
past have supported for example the
no-fly no-buy the NRA has been adamantly
opposed to that I believe they still are
so I think that but now having the
president say I'm ok with these things
will will mean a lot to someone call
break the spell for me I'm not running
for reelection obviously freed from
those kind of concerns but I have to say
in the past I've supported a lot of
measures at the end of an array has not
supported and now that you're not
running for re-election do you feel more
empowered to speak up against the NRA
and the president ways that you didn't
feel you could do before oh you bet it
goes without saying that you're freed of
political considerations and that's one
of the things that led me to to make
this decision I didn't want to go for
this last year you know just beholden to
to one the time involved a fundraising
and everything else I thought it was
important that somebody stand up and I'm
very concerned about the direction of
the administration on a number of issues
and I thought somebody needed to stay
though let me ask you this question
about raising the age to 21 the
Washington Post did some counting here
and found that of the 153 mass shooting
since 1966 only 18 of them were
committed by people under the age of 21
and I think the numbers even smaller who
used assault weapons of the kind you're
trying to limit so that seems like a
very small portion of this larger
question we're trying to fix here well I
think you'll get a small portion there
the bump stocks have only been used once
in one shooting but it was a an awful
awful shooting that needs to be done if
you do the no-fly no-buy list you've
taken care of another segment so I think
there's a number of things that we can
do it if we do them all I think will
make a difference let me ask about the
bigger question of gun violence in
America one of the things that some
people would like is more study by the
CDC and other to cover it like a healthy
about you is that something you would
support yes I would I think that there
are things that that can be useful to
legislators as we make decisions and you
know findings of the CDC would be
helpful in that regard so Congress would
have to undo a lot of that to happen and
I think they can and will on this I'm
fascinated about yeah I feel more
empowered now to speak up but why is it
I've heard Republicans who are in office
now say what we're seeing is crazytown
and they're not speaking up even when
they disagree with the president why
don't people who disagree feel that they
cannot stand up and speak up against him
one it's the pure volume of it I mean if
you were asked or if you answered every
time the press is saying what do you
make of the president's latest tweets it
gets tiresome it frankly does and so a
lot of it isn't just that they're afraid
to speak out it's just that they want to
spend their time on other things and you
could go day after day just responding
to the president or the latest you know
whatever it is coming out of the White
House senator we would be remiss if we
didn't ask you about daca and the fate
of the 700,000 young men and women who
are waiting to see what happens on
immigration can you tell us any well you
know this we tried we had a good week of
debate and and went nowhere
we have sort of a deadline coming up
March 5th but the courts have ruled that
these kids can't be restricted from
renewing so without a real deadline it's
going to be tough to move for sure I've
introduced legislation along with Heidi
Heitkamp that says all right we'll have
three years of extension of daca will
codify daca so it's constitutional in
exchange for three years of the
President's budget request on the border
so it's it's I think a reasonable trade
I hope that the White House will take
that up and at least will give three
years extension and and more certainty
for these kids I think frankly right now
it's probably the best we can do but you
are heading up to New Hampshire for an
event that's described as meeting with
business leaders with a chance to meet
with major Party presidential candidates
should we anything about that about your
plans for 2020 I got an invitation I
accept it New Hampshire politics just
know it is a nice state
mitigating it already I can't go I have
a pedicure in pérouse right holiday in
Iowa right exactly it's lovely in
January Senator Jeff really leave them
in Senate but not American politics it's
great to see you thanks for your time
thank you all thanks